beyond inhumane that's how a UN official
has described the situation in Yarmouk
refugee camp in Damascus Syria Isis
fighters are in control of nearly 60% of
the camp after entering on April 1st
18,000 residents remain trapped inside
including 3,500 children but what
exactly is yet a MOOC and how did things
spiral out of control the MOOC is the
largest Palestinian refugee camp in
Syria it was established in 1957 and
became one of the most densely populated
districts in the Syrian capital in 2011
when the Syrian uprising began 150
thousand people lived in Yarmouk mostly
Palestinian refugees several of the
camp's residents protested against
President Bashar al-assad and many were
jailbird kills in 2012 anti-government
rebels took control of the camp the
government along with its Palestinian
allies responded by placing the camp
under siege for more than two years now
life in the besieged Yarmouk refugee
camp has been unbearable and now with
Isis in the picture it's only gotten
worse here's what journalist Talal a
Lian who's in touch with camp residents
told me there hasn't been food in the
camp save a few aid distributions here
and there for almost two and a half
years there hasn't been running water in
the camp for over 200 days the only
source of water within the camp has been
taken over by Isis
moreover medical aid and medical
facilities within the camp are almost
entirely non-existent the only running
Hospital within the camp was shelled a
few days ago to make matters worse yet
moocs residents are caught in the middle
of fierce fighting from above the Syrian
Air Force has dropped barrel bombs on
the camp several times and on the ground
battles raged between rebel forces and
Isis fighters who've teamed up with al
Qaeda affiliate Japeth and us from Isis
snipers have fired from building
rooftops and there have even been
reports of beheadings to further
complicate things the SM government has
reportedly offered to provide weapons to
Palestinian fighters in the camp against
Isis UN officials are calling for
humanitarian
access and the safe passage and
evacuation of civilians to be allowed
the main UN agency on the ground says 94
people have been evacuated from the camp
and that no aid has been able to enter
since April 1st in the meantime the
nightmare and yet MOOC drags on as his
residents continue to suffer and starve
with no end in sight many are asking why
did it take Isis entering get a move for
people to wake up to this ongoing
catastrophe to cognise shame